فكرة أن الرئيس بايدن أمر
2500 من أفراد الخدمة بالخروج والآن
يرسل ما يصل إلى 5000 من أفراد الخدمة مرة أخرى ،
فهذا لا
يظهر في ظاهرها أن السابق أن الخروج كان
مخططًا بشكل غير لائق ، ومرة أخرى ان
روا لي قبل بضعة أشهر بشأن هذ
.  البرنامج الذي كنت تعتقد أنه من
المحتمل تمامًا أن يتولى طالبان
السيطرة على البلاد ، لكن الرئيس
بايدن في الشهر الماضي اقتبس
من احتمالية
اجتياح طالبان لكل شيء ومن
غير المرجح أن يكون امتلاك البلد بأكمله
فعل ما
فعله الرئيس هو التأكد من أننا كنا قادرين
على التكيف مع أي شيء يحدث على
الأرض أه وحقيقة أننا قلنا
أنه أرسل قوات إضافية في الداخل لدينا
تلك القوات على أهبة الاستعداد
للذهاب في حال أه ذلك  تحرك هذا
في اتجاه احتجنا فيه إلى وجود
قوات لضمان
سلامة وأمن أفرادنا لضمان أن نتمكن أيضًا من
بذل كل ما في وسعنا
لإخراج هؤلاء من أفغانستان  الأفغان الأكثر
عرضة للخطر هذا هو بالضبط ما نفعله ، فلماذا
لا يكون لديك القوات هناك
ثم ندع ذلك يحدث أولاً قبل
إخراجهم مرة أخرى ، أعود إلى ما
كنا نتحدث عنه قبل بضع دقائق
وهو هذا الوضع  إذا لم أكن
مستدامًا سواء أحببته أم لا أه كان هناك اتفاق
على خروج القوات في
الأول من مايو لولاها لم نبدأ هذه
العملية وهو ما فعله الرئيس
أه ورأى طالبان ثم
كنا قد عدنا  الحرب مع
طالبان وكنا قد عدنا إلى الحرب مع
عشرات الآلاف من الجنود الذين اضطروا إلى
الدخول لأن 2500 جندي كان لدينا هناك
والقوة الجوية لم تكن
كافية للتعامل مع الوضع
خاصة أننا نرى للأسف
خواء  قوات الأمن
الأفغانية وبالمناسبة من منظور
منافسينا الاستراتيجيين في جميع أنحاء العالم ،
لا يوجد شيء يرغبون فيه أكثر
من رؤيتنا في أفغانستان
لمدة خمسة وعشرين عامًا أخرى ، إنه
ببساطة ليس في الوطن  من أجل المصلحة العامة ،
تستمر في تغيير الموضوع إلى ما إذا كان
يجب أن نكون هناك إلى الأبد أم لا ، وأنا
لا أتحدث عن ذلك ، أنا أتحدث
عما إذا كان هذا الخروج قد تم
بشكل صحيح
مع إخراج جميع أعضاء الخدمة
قبل هؤلاء الأمريكيين وأولئك
المترجمين الأفغان  يمكن أن نخرج هذا ما
أتحدث عنه ومن ثم عليك أن
ترسل الناس مرة أخرى في تلك العروض ، هذا
تعريف لأوه ما كان يجب علينا إخراج
تلك القوات لأنه يتعين علينا الآن
إرسال ضعف هذا العدد مرة أخرى
أعتقد ذلك  يوضح أننا كنا مستعدين
، كان الرئيس مستعدًا لكل حالة
طوارئ لأن هذه الخطوة إلى الأمام كانت لدينا
تلك القوات في متناول اليد
وتمكنا من الانتشار
بسرعة كبيرة مرة أخرى للتأكد من أننا يمكن أن
نتحرك بأمان
وأمان حسب الوضع على الأرض
يقال إن تغيير الصين مستعدة
للاعتراف بطالبان كحكومة شرعية ،
فهل تفكر إدارة بايدن في فعل
ذلك حكومة أفغانية مستقبلية تدعم
الحقوق الأساسية
من
أهلها ولا تأوي إرهابيين
أه حكومة نستطيع العمل معها
وأه والعكس بالعكس
حكومة لا تفعل
ذلك ولا تحترم الحقوق الأساسية
لشعبها بما في ذلك النساء والفتيات أه
ذاك أه تابع  أن أه يأوي
مجموعات إرهابية لها مخططات على
الولايات المتحدة حلفاءنا
وشركائنا بالتأكيد لن
يحدث ذلك وأكثر من ذلك لدرجة
أن طالبان لها مصلحة ذاتية
إذا كانت تقود الحكومة
الأفغانية بمساعدة المجتمع الدولي
دعم المجتمع الدولي
لن يتم رفع أي من هذه العقوبات القادمة لن يتم رفع قدرتهم
على السفر
لن تحدث إذا لم يحافظوا
على الحقوق الأساسية للشعب
الأفغاني وإذا عادوا إلى دعم أو
إيواء الإرهابيين  من قد يصدمنا
جيدًا ، أعني أنه يبدو وكأنه لا ،
فلن تتعرف عليه أبدًا لأنه بناءً
على ما نعرفه عن طالبان ، فإنهم
لا يحترمون حقوق wo.  الرجال
والفتيات هناك تقارير من أفغانستان في
الوقت الحالي تفيد بأنهم يجبرون
الفتيات الصغيرات على
العبودية الجنسية ،
هذه أشياء مؤلمة للقلب ،
لقد التقيت بنفسي كما أعلم أنك لديك
مع نساء رائعات كن
قائدات في أفغانستان  على مدار العشرين
عامًا الماضية ، الذين عززوا حقوق
النساء والفتيات من خلال
دعمنا القوي جدًا ،
قابلت عددًا منهم قبل بضعة أشهر فقط
في المرة الأخيرة التي كنت فيها في كابول هذا
الربيع ، وأعتقد أن ذلك من واجب
المجتمع الدولي  بما في ذلك
الولايات المتحدة لفعل كل ما في وسعنا
باستخدام كل أداة لدينا اقتصادية
دبلوماسية سياسية
للعمل على الحفاظ
على حقوقهم وفي نفس الوقت كما
قلت
لنتأكد من أه إذا
لم تفعل طالبان ذلك إذا كانت مسؤولة أه ذاك  أم
أه من الواضح أنها تواجه أه العقوبات
أه لأه لم تتمسك بتلك
الحقوق وسنفعل كل ما في وسعنا
للتأكد من ذلك